20 years ago I did research and I showed
what I called the compromise effect
whereby depending on what products you
you place in front of consumers they
tend to take the middle option well a
year ago a doctoral student here at
Stanford Tali wife and I conducted a
study where we try to replicate that
compromise effect this time however we
showed the participants some of the
information that's available on Amazon
we showed them some other cameras the
same product categories we used back in
1992 and we show them reviews so we
showed them some of the information
available to consumers today what
happened
the compromise effect disappeared and
that's really the essence of what has
changed from making decisions in
relative terms in the old days where you
make decisions based on the set of
options that is placed in front of you
to the way you make decisions today
which means that today you no longer
have to rely on what marketers choose to
show you
the new reality is one where the key is
the absolute value that you provide
customers customers will rely much more
on what others are saying and much less
on their past history with your product
about the brand or about the fact that
your product was placed in the movies or
it had the recommend being recommended
by some celebrity they really rely on
what others are saying which in many
categories simply reflects more or less
the truth and you're likely experienced
with that product even though you hear
all those mantras even today that brands
have never been more important and the
best investment a marketer can make is
in loyalty we disagree we feel that
actually the important of loyalty and
brands and persuasion is diminishing and
to the extent that your customers can
assess quality directly spending money
on persuasion for example through
advertising may be a waste of money
one good way to do it is to go with the
product itself to focus on the product
itself you know if you view some
commercials for some of the high-tech
companies now that promote phones and
they really feature specific they look
at the highlight the the specific
features they create interest through
reviews there are a different method to
seed product to encourage influencers to
talk about the product again in a
totally authentic and honest way but
it's much more focused on product than
brand
instead of measuring consumers existing
preferences to predict the future
preferences you have to recognize the
reality where consumers make decisions
today based on reviews that are
available today which means that what
you need to do is to find out what
reviewers are saying today who are the
most influential reviewers and how can
we help them recognize the absolute
value of our products in the old days
and unjust
perhaps ten years ago marketers were
very much in control they could decide
what products to show consumers they
could build a brand's and as they did
they could invest in loyalty and they
could spend money on advertising which
was effective in inducing purchase
decisions today all those tools are
becoming less important marketers are
much less in control and they need to
determine where they are go along with
their situation in terms of the way
their customers are making decisions
there is no way for marketers to change
that because that is the way consumers
are making decisions today and there's
really no way back